go
let's go ahead and go live
okay hi everyone so back for another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others and i see there are
still some questions left over from last
week
there's one from rios
asking is the number zero a natural
number or just an integer well
usually when people say natural numbers
they mean
numbers one two three five and they
don't include zero
has a very weird history you know we
think of zero as being a pretty natural
and obvious concept today
but for a long time in the history of
people doing calculations in math
xero was an extremely un uh unfamiliar
idea
and and people made all kinds of weird
mistakes and so on as a result like i
think the romans
didn't have a concept of zero their
number system just
firmly started at one and so when they
had to do calculations for calendars for
example
where it was important to just say
things start at the beginning of the
year
they had some whole elaborate way of
dealing with that and they managed to
get it wrong
and when first they set up the what's
now
called the julian calendar it's not the
calendar we use today it's the kind
that was used um in up to the 1500s some
places 1600 some places a little bit
later than that
but it was a calendar which added uh i
guess it added the month
of august if i remember correctly named
after augustus caesar i think
um and uh you know they added months to
try and keep
the uh time it takes the earth to go
around the sun
aligned with the actual length of a year
and days that they had worked out and
that's why we have leap years and things
like that to try and deal with the fact
that
the actual time it takes the earth to go
around the sun is not
365 days it's 365.25
2481 i think days um so in other words
it's it's some
but any case the romans didn't have all
that stuff straight and they didn't have
a notion of zero and that caused their
whole
calculation of calendars to get
extremely confused
and i would say the notion of zero i
mean i think there's early um
evidence from i think there's an early
thing from cambodia
some early things from india about
people noticing the idea of zero but i
think the idea of zero
as something that was a serious number
that you could
think about was something really of the
probably
1400s ish timeframe
that that that became started to be
really understood i mean
nowadays it's kind of obvious you're
just counting numbers down and
and you get uh you know you get below
two one
whoop what's next well there's just zero
then there's minus one etcetera etcetera
etcetera that wasn't obvious to people
for a long time
you could do that people would say there
is no notion of zero because it's
nothing
so it was very very confusing in fact
back in
um when was it around 1500 i think a guy
called cardano
um was much responsible for
a strangely pretty much the same time
really taking negative numbers seriously
and taking complex numbers numbers that
involve the square root of minus one
seriously um and for us complex numbers
are sort of a slightly more elaborate
concept one doesn't learn about until
one's doing i don't know where one
learns about it maybe doing pre-calculus
or something
um whereas negative numbers are things
everybody knows about
um cardano got involved with both of
those because he was trying to solve
cubic equations equations with
x cubes in them um and that
required both of those ideas
so let's see a question here
from free men how do you do calculus on
round objects like spheres or donuts
hmm um
um i'm not sure quite what do calculus
means but but um uh
you know um
so calculus what is the idea of calculus
okay the the basic idea of calculus
is if you've got let's say
something that is changing its value
with time
so you can plot that as a graph you
could say
this thing is it's going up it's coming
down it's going up it's coming down i
don't know something like um well in our
current time
you know number of infections measured
by such and such a thing as a function
of time it has some curve
okay so we got this curve going as a
function of time
now there are a couple of things that
are interesting to do with that curve
and they're things which calculus talks
a lot about one is to find
the slope of the curve at every point
and the other is to find the area under
the curve so let's talk about the slope
of the curve
so let's say we have just a straight
line going up then the slope of that
curve is constant
so uh that that's some that that we just
say the slope of the curve is whatever
it is it's like when you're going down a
hill or something in a car
and it says you know 15 gradient or
something that's the
that's the slope of the hill for every
for every uh
one unit you go along you go 15
down or up so that slope is just
that ratio of the amount you go up to
the amount you go across
um so if the if it's just a a flat
uh line that flat uh just a straight
line
then then the slope is constant okay so
the next case is
what happens if instead it's going up
like
a quadratic like x squared it's going up
like this
um then what's the slope as a function
of position
turns out the slope the the slope
gradually increases as you go further
and the amount and increases turns out
to be proportional
to how far along you've gone so so
that's the sort of uh that's another
typical result
okay so what's the calculus version of
this the slope
is called the derivative of the of the
of the well okay so if we think about
this thing let's say as a function of
time
we have some some value as a function of
time let's call it f
of t where t is time so f is some
function
that tells us just how uh how high it's
going to be
at a particular time so then the
derivative
of f of t with respect to t
is the slope of that curve that's
defined by f of t
um so derivative is just the slope of f
of t and there are rules about
derivatives so for example
if f of t is a constant times
times t let's say a times t then the
derivative is just
a so that just means it's a it's going
in a straight line and the straight line
has slope
a then the derivative is just a if
if the um if the if f of t is t squared
a parabola then the rule for taking
derivatives says
that the derivative of f of t is two t
and in general if the if the curve was t
to the power
n the derivative would be n times uh t
to the power n minus one
okay so that's that's first big bucket
of calculus
has to do with with uh uh finding slopes
of curves
okay the other and that's about uh
differential calculus derivatives
the other big bucket of calculus has to
do with integrals
and integrals are working out the area
under the curve
so for example let's say we have a just
something that's completely flat
and we say what's the area under this
curve well
the the area under the curve is going to
be if we start from the beginning
the area is going to be well that first
rectangle plus the second plus the third
plus whatever
the the total area is going to increase
linearly
as we go as we go across so in other
words
if we're finding the integral of that if
f of t is just a constant
then the integral of f of t is just t
times that constant value
it's just it's just the area of that
sort of big rectangle made by whatever
the value of f of t
is um going for whatever distance you
you choose to go for
well then it turns out the um
if you have something which has a a as a
straight line
then the integral the area under that
straight line is a parabola
and in general the thing you realize is
that
uh taking slopes and finding areas
are inverses of each other so in other
words if you
find the area under this
uh under this curve and then you find
the slope
of the area under the curve that's equal
to the original curve
that sorry that's equal to the original
function so the the slope
of the integral of f of t the derivative
of the integral of f of t
is just f of t itself and the same is
true the other way around if you work
out
the um uh the the slope
and then you start aggregating it to
find out the area under
under the function you get from the
slope you'll get back to the original
function again
so derivatives and integrals are are
inverse functions
and and the main sort of work of
calculus as people learn it in school
is knowing if you have a formula like a
formula like i don't know x
log x or something um to figure out
what's the derivative of that
as a function of x and what's the
integral of that as a function of x
and so you learn things like the
integral of log x
is x log x i think at least minus x
actually
um and uh it's it's much easier
to do derivatives than it is to do
integrals there's a completely
systematic procedure
for working out the derivative of
anything basically when you have
if you can write something as a function
f of g
of h of x then when you take the
derivative of that those functions kind
of unpeel
themselves and it's easy to write down
the answer so derivatives are pretty
systematic and easy to take
integrals are a much more complicated
story i mentioned that integrals and
derivatives are inverses of each other
so in a sense when you're doing an
integral
what you want to do is find a result
such that if you took the derivative of
that result you get back to the original
function again
and just knowing sort of how to how to
shoot the right target
to get the integral that um to get that
function which when differentiated will
give you the original thing again
that's tricky business and the uh
when people learn calculus that's one of
the sort of difficult things to do
and um it's it's something which
um okay so in in mathematica will from
alpha
in wolfram language uh we've kind of
become the
the world's go-to place to get those
kinds of things done
um and uh the way the way uh
we do it is using a bunch of sort of
sophisticated mathematical ideas
which allow uh very wide class of
integrals to be computed
but not even if you were taking the
integral of i don't know
um i don't know x over sine
x plus one or something it's a slightly
tricky integral to do
um we would get the result for that
integral in terms of some very elaborate
mathematical function that people
uh don't don't hear about in in school
typically
and then actually the main work is to
simplify that very complicated
mathematical function
to something that people can recognize
and understand
but um the the the job of kind of
working out
uh analytically working out as formulas
integrals that's a tricky thing to do
and um in in general there are all kinds
of functions where
uh well you know if you say what's the
integral of of uh
okay so i have a i have kind of a
mission to make here which is that
i started using computers to do math
um back when i was a mid-teenager
because i didn't kind of like doing all
this math stuff by hand myself
and so i've uh i've been a a person
who's done many integrals in their life
essentially all on a computer so if you
ask me as a human
to do integrals i'm really crummy at it
um i
it's uh uh when my
older daughter was learning calculus i
think i annoyed her
uh she's now uh in the process of
becoming a professional mathematician
but that's a
that's an independent footnote um but uh
uh the um i think i annoyed her by
saying
you know watching her do integrals by
hand it's like
i didn't think humans still did any of
that kind of stuff
um because i certainly haven't done it
as a human for more than 40 years now
um but any case uh so i'm a bad person
to ask
you know what's an integral of what but
i think um i have to really think about
it you know what the integral of um
of these different functions is um but
uh uh some integrals you can like just
do systematically other integrals that
seem like they're
pretty simple functions are really hard
to do like the integral of
sine of sine of x i know that integral
can't be done in terms of ordinary
functions that you would find in
standard textbooks and so on
uh it can be done in terms of a very
ornate bivariate hypergeometric function
but like sine of sine of sine of x
sort of three nested trigonometric
functions i think that integral cannot
be done
in terms of any ordinary uh mathematical
functions that that people have thought
about
when i say it can't be done i just mean
there isn't a formula for
for what that integral is if you just
wanted to work out what's the value of
that integral
taking that curve a certain distance
well there'll be some number and you can
work that out
okay so the original question was about
doing calculus uh
on um on spheres and and doughnuts and
things like that
what i've been describing is sort of
ordinary so-called univariate calculus
single variable calculus
where it's just some function as a
function of time or
some function as a function of x and so
on but you can also do
multivariate calculus where you say
let's look not at a curve but a whole
surface
let's say we look at the height as a
function of position in the xy plane and
we've got some
whole landscape and got a big mountain
there and so on and so on and so on
and so then you can ask questions like
what's the generalization of the idea of
slope
for this whole like mountain scape and
that's a thing
instead of it being just a number what
the slope is
it's a it's a direction and a number
it's a gradient vector
so for example that would be you're at
the top of mount everest
which way down is the one that is the
fastest down
so it might be that some some way it's
very shallow curve down the mountain
another way it's very steep
so what one is what one does in
multivariate calculus is often to find
the gradient
of this uh height function and that
gradient is a vector
which points down the sort of steepest
going down direction
of the mountain so to speak and that's
sort of the beginning of multivariate
calculus
you can also consider uh integrals where
you're working out
not what is the area under the curve but
like what's the
volume of the mountain so to speak or
what's the um
uh the volume of some figure you know
some cone or something like this
okay so uh an even more elaborate thing
is when you are looking at functions
not just as a function of one variable
just a curve as a function of position
not just
as a you know height as a function of of
position in the plane
but instead you're saying i'm on the
surface of a sphere
and now i'm going to have some function
on the first surface of a sphere so
so that would be like considering you
know the mountains on the earth
considering that the earth is a sphere
like you have a very small asteroid and
you're asking
uh for you know the height as a function
of of position around the asteroid it
gets a lot trickier
because on the earth for example the
earth is mostly a sphere
and we can just start talking about the
the height locally on the sphere but if
the whole thing
is a really weird shape it's a more
complicated issue to define what you
mean by height and so on
so there's a lot of results about
calculus
that apply to working out integrals and
things like that
over more complicated shapes there's a
bunch of very wonderful
beautiful mathematical results having to
do with working out
uh integrals of functions where the
function is defined
over the surface of let's say a sphere
or a doughnut and
um it turns out that certain kinds of
results
for certain integrals the answer that
you get
depends only on the number of holes in
the object
so a sphere is something which has genus
zero it has no holes in it
a doughnut standard doughnut with a hole
in the middle
i it always confused me when i was a kid
in england and i
would sometimes read uh textbooks and
they were american textbooks
and they would talk about and and they
meant taurus says
um they meant things with you know with
with holes in the middle that sort of
circle around the outside a hole in the
middle
that always really confused me because
in england at least at that time
a donut was a thing usually filled with
jam
that was just a blob of of stuff it
didn't have any hole in the middle of it
so i i couldn't understand what these uh
sort of
topological structures with holes in
them but anyway an american
standard doughnut uh with with one hole
um that's a genus one object it turns
out that
one of the surprising things is that
some of these results about calculus
depend uh only on the number of holes so
if you had a two hole doughnut
you would get um you get certain results
and and so on it only depends on the
number of holes
and there's a bunch of really nice
mathematical results related to that
which um i i think uh let me not get
into describing those in detail here
all right let's see another question
here from
all ether
um if you could change how we measure
time
would you and to what
gosh i'm not sure at what level we're
talking about here um
you know it's a time goes by
we make certain um uh
uh somewhat um uh
arbitrary decisions about what
the um um uh
you know how how long is the second
how long is a minute how long is an hour
how long is a day how long is a week
some of them are not so arbitrary a day
we pretty much want to be more or less
the time it takes the earth to go around
the sun because that's a
that's a sort of a natural thing where
we can say well
you know each day each time you get up
in the morning each day we want
something to happen
a year is also not so arbitrary because
it's the
roughly the time it takes the earth to
go around the sun
a month well there's a lunar month the
time it takes the moon to go around the
earth that's about 28 days
um we've chosen to make our standard
in the standard calendar we've chosen to
make our months be 12 months and they
have this rather awkward stuff with some
have 30 days 31 days etc
um and uh these are so
some you know the the anchor points are
more or less
you know the um uh
uh you know a day is a day because
that's the time it takes earth to go
around
uh a year is is a year roughly
because it's some approximation to the
time it takes to go around the sun a
month
roughly the time it takes the time that
the phase of the moon to rotate or the
moon to go around the earth
um a second i suppose is roughly you
know one heartbeat
i don't know whether that's some uh um
you know i don't know really whether
that's where it came from but that is
there is something that that's there
you know the idea of measuring uh time
with um you know 60 minutes an hour 24
hours a day
certainly 60 minutes an hour came from
the babylonians who are very into base
60
base 60 is really convenient because you
can divide
60 and you know if you if you want to
say i've got a i've got i'm measuring
everything in 60ths
and how much you know what i can have a
half of the 60th and that's still a
whole number
i can have a quarter of a 60th and um
uh yeah that's still a whole number and
a quarter of a 60th is 15
15 you know like 15 minutes a quarter of
an hour type thing
um so they're they're it's convenient to
have
60 as the number of minutes an hour if
you want to divide
an hour like you're saying quarter of an
hour it's still a whole number of
minutes and so on
um i think people occasionally
i don't know things like seven days in a
week well that something
certainly existed um i think that
existed in babylonian times
um i don't know is that a good idea is
that a bad idea it's like if you want to
really
you know uh sort of um uh
i don't know what it what would how it
would change society if we had nine day
weeks or five day weeks
i'm not sure um i mean we might feel
more relaxed we might feel less relaxed
i don't really know
um you know that people who have these
proposals occasionally
to um to make 25 hours in a day i'm not
sure why we would do that
i think these questions about
making it more convenient to calculate
things um
it's always it's always worth
remembering that
you know now that we have computers we
can kind of calculate a way around
anything
um and it's not so sometimes it's
convenient to be able to do sort of
estimation of things i
tell a a story about um
maybe i told it on one of these before
but but um
tell when i was growing up in england
um the uh the currency
in england money was not decimal
so it um it was there were pounds
shillings and pence
and there were uh 12
pennies in a shilling and 20 shillings
in a pound
and just for good measure a guinea was
21 shillings
um but in any case so it was a it was
something where
you know uh 12 pennies and a shilling uh
20 shillings in a pound
so it wasn't decimal currency it's not
like in in the us where they're just 100
cents in each dollar
and so on i remember telling some
teacher when i was like
probably six years old i would guess
that
i was i was very pleased with the fact
that i'd figured out that money didn't
have to work this way that you could
perfectly well have
uh you know defined prices for things in
decimals
and this teacher was like but it's been
the way it is
for for you know a thousand years it's
never going to change
and i was like well it's really silly
well then about a year or two later it
was announced that in fact
uh britain was going to change to having
decimal money
and that was going to happen in 1970 um
and so it was like oh okay cool but what
was interesting to see was
how confused or not people got with
decimal money
relative to having had a thousand years
or whatever of pounds shillings pence
um the and i remember that on television
you know for
for a year beforehand they used to have
these decimalization programs about you
know how to estimate money with
with decimal money et cetera et cetera
et cetera and um
it was uh you know i think nobody knew
how confused people were going to be
as it turns out it was really it was
interesting the day i mean i was 10
years old or something it was
the day when the money changed and like
you
you would hand in money in in the old
old currency and you get back money in
new currency
and the most interesting thing to me was
that people were not confused
that extremely quickly people uh you
know
were able to compute things just fine
with decimal currency
and it wasn't like oh i'm so confused i
don't know you know i don't know how to
do this now i know what's happened
in more recent times and i haven't lived
there for a long time i know they went
from measuring temperature and
fahrenheit to measuring temperature in
celsius
and i don't know how confusing that's
been my guess is not very
all right next question here um
well okay so there's a question here
from brian
um about that there are clouds of things
like alcohols
in space and the question is
could there
be sort of life
that emerges from all of these
life-like molecules that exist in in
molecular clouds in space
um tough business so most of what's out
in for example interstellar space is
mostly just hydrogen that's it
just hydrogen but there are some more
complicated molecules
there are molecules that have carbon and
hydrogen some
some slightly longer hydrocarbon type
molecules some i think with oxygen as
well
there are molecules out there that are
some of the molecules that we find
in living systems um not are huge
molecules like
molecules that are you know decent
length
carbon and hydrogen molecules those
molecules arise in space
by a process very different it's not by
chemical processes you know in chemistry
when you do chemical reactions molecules
are being broken up
other molecules other atoms that
molecules are attaching themselves and
so on
that that's happening in the sort of
let's say in a liquid chemical reaction
that's happening when just molecules and
liquid run into each other and so on
in space the process is is uh in a style
of space there just aren't very many
molecules around
and so a common thing that happens is
these molecules just sort of
uh run into each other uh just instead
of free space two molecules will run
into each other and then maybe they'll
they'll get attached they're also
interstellar grains
a little tiny dust grains on which uh
different kinds of reactions can happen
but they tend to be very different kinds
of of processes for building up
molecules and the ones that you see in
standard chemistry on earth
so you build up sort of the the set of
molecules you build up as a different
and somewhat exotic set of molecules
can those molecules sort of could you
expect that those molecules would
combine
and make still more complicated
molecules well maybe but not very fast
it's not like a chemical reaction on
earth where you could have this you know
uh beaker of of of liquids where they're
just
you know trillions and trillions of
molecules colliding all the time in
space it's like
well be you know be glad if your
molecules collide every thousand years
or something so it's it's a much slower
process
now you know it's a very slippery slope
to understand
what uh counts as something being alive
let me not get into that whole
discussion um i think
that um the thing to say is is can one
expect that on a short time scale
uh things you know and just individual
molecules hanging around in space
will combine to make sort of the kind of
collections of molecules that we're used
to with life on earth
that's a that's a really long road um i
mean
in in the in the early earth a few
billion years ago
things were really set up so that lots
and lots of molecules were colliding all
the time
and it was much easier to build up more
complicated chemical processes and so on
to make things that were the complicated
molecules that have made life on earth
i don't think that's the kind of thing
we can expect to have happen in
interstellar space uh
question from pamenides uh a curious
name given the question
speaking of the romans do you think
latin is a better language than english
for science and mathematics
oh boy well latin is a very
organized language you know english is a
language which is an amalgam of many
different pieces
from many different sources and there
are so many exceptions in english
in in latin there are many fewer
exceptions i mean you know when i was a
kid learning latin a lot of what you
learned was the
exceptions you know the verbs that
decline in a weird way
um you know uh in english it would be
you know i am you
are he is um she is whatever uh
we are uh you are they are okay that
wasn't so irregular
but um you know in in um some as
est sumus ester sunt right that's the
latin
for that and and that's the that's um
uh you know those are all sort of words
that sound a bit different but they all
come together to be
parts of of of of um
of of um inflecting um
the word for for to be present tense of
of the verb for to be um so english has
just
a ton more um uh
sort of unusual uh verb forms
unusual uh grammatical constructions and
so on i mean as a good example of this
you know
a latin grammar book is a little thin
thing you can kind of learn in a little
while
you know because i've been interested in
natural language understanding for
computers i have you know english
grammar books that are fairly complete
english grammar books
and they're big thick thousand page you
know 1500 page documents because english
is so full of
weird exceptions and so on so latinism
is a much more systematic language in
many ways
it's also a language that uh but it's a
it's a language that obviously didn't
get to express
a lot of things that are relevant for
science and technology today
um it's uh um you know i actually have a
a friend who's a
classics professor at oxford university
and um
uh he has the the curious job of doing
the following thing
so at oxford university they give
honorary degrees sometimes to uh
to distinguish people from different
fields um
and uh some of those people have you
know are people who do computer stuff or
biochemistry or something like this
and at oxford university probably since
the 1200s they've had a tradition
of explaining the achievements of their
honorary degree recipients
by a speech given in latin well
the question is if you're giving a
speech in latin
you have to describe the accomplishments
of somebody who's worked on parallel
computing or worked on
the physics of anti-antimatter or
something like this
the question is how do you describe that
in latin given that
the the language of latin is uh is a
language which has
has uh has not been being added to in
recent years so my friend has the
has the curious job of trying to make up
the ways of explaining in a few words um
what um uh uh what
something a thing like a computer i know
he's got a a word for a computer in
latin i don't i don't remember what it
is
um but uh uh that he uses for these uh
for these for these speeches and so on
but obviously you have to adapt latin
for modern times if you're going to do
that
now you know in the history of these
things there was a time
when latin was really the the language
of of
of scholarship the language of
intellectual work i mean i think that
was
probably the case from from the time of
the roman empire
um right up through i would say um
and into this probably into the 1700s um
and uh that was something partly driven
by
uh the catholic church and the the
dominance of
of that um but it extended to to other
places as well
um that you know if you wanted to
explain something and you wanted it to
have uh serious readership
and it was an intellectual thing you
would write it in latin
um and and that was probably a good
thing because you didn't have to write
in english and french and german
and you know in in in spanish whatever
all these languages as they emerged
were all separate languages but if you
wanted to write your
your great scientific work you just
write in latin everybody would would
know how to read it
um and and that kind of survived up
until as i say about the 1700s
when things started getting written in
in different languages i i mean
predominantly at that time
english german french those were the
most common languages
um and really that that continued until
probably
after the second world war when uh
when really english became the dominant
language for scientific discourse
um there's still a certain amount in
french
france has been a country that's been
very proudly trying to maintain its
language
um uh you know against the the forces of
of corruption from words being imported
from other places
um and uh i think
um uh it's so it's one of these
languages where there's actually an
institute that is trying to standardize
the language
and says you know i don't know whether
you can say the blockchain
um in french but you know there'll be
words which are like no
you know you can't say that in french
it's not a it's not the right word
um it's uh um but any case the
the when latin was kind of on its way
out
1600s early 1700s as a universal
language that actually drove a bunch of
development
um it actually was part of the impetus
for mathematical notation
because there was sort of an idea well
let's at least even if we lose the
language part of it
at least let's have the math be
something that's internationalized and
people like gottfried leibniz were much
involved in
in that effort it's also led to the idea
at that time of making what were called
at that time philosophical languages
languages which could express meaning
but without having specific words from
particular languages
and sometimes those languages would get
written in strange uh
strange sort of runic scripts um that
was supposed to be something which is
sort of a language independent language
so to speak
that would express purely the meaning
without the
the sort of the surface level of actual
expression in terms of historically
defined words in particular languages
um that effort of making philosophical
languages didn't really make it in the
1600s
and it kind of got put on the back
burner for the last 300 years
um now actually i've been super
interested in in doing that and in fact
our wolfram language
is kind of a a run-up to being able to
do that it's a sort of computational
language for describing the world
um and uh what i'm uh i'm very
interested in the idea
of having a language that is a
systematic language that can be
understood by a computer
that could express the kinds of things
that i'm expressing to you now
um we've obviously done a lot of work on
this in things like wolf and alpha where
we're translating english into this sort
of precise symbolic internal language
that allows us to do computation but i
think now the idea of philosophical
language which was born
out of this move from latin in the 1600s
and early 1700s i think that idea
which has has kind of not really been
developed in the last 300 years
it's going to be one of my next projects
to try and really develop that it's
something that's important for practical
things in the world
it's important for if we write a legal
contract that says you know
person a must do whatever this thing and
that thing and the other thing
you have to write that in a way that's
very well defined
so that you don't have to argue about
well did person a do what they said in
the contract they should do and so on
and um traditionally that's been written
in basically let's say english or
whatever
native language one's using and sort of
legalese which is an attempt to you know
say things like um what's that a good
example
uh you know the following you know
conditions uh
um uh including but not limited to
the following conditions you know that
phrase including but not limited to
is basically saying there's a list of
things but there might be something else
and just because the thing that was a
there's something else that was
mentioned
was what actually turned out to be
important you shouldn't ignore that
etc etc etc but that phrase is a piece
of sort of legalese
um that is an attempt to make more
precise what would otherwise be
expressed in english
if you have a sort of true symbolic
discourse language as i'm calling it
it's kind of a derivative of these
philosophical languages if you have a
true thing like that
then you don't you get to precisely
define what you want to say
i mean i might say there have been
various attempts to make alternative
natural languages
uh for talking about things i would say
that there was a big push on those
things in the late 1800s early 1900s
most famous of those is esperanto which
was a language which was intended to
basically
simplify a bunch of the standard
european languages
and it lasted for a while but it's it's
not ever received a really huge
following partly i think in modern times
because english has been so successful
as a language that
a large large number of people know
let's see
um
okay oh boy lots of questions
um okay there's a
clarification from freeman here about
the question about calculus on spheres
and doughnuts and things
um uh
the question about this is the question
about how you do calculus
when you've got hills that are on the
surface of the earth
or worse on the surface of a little
asteroid um
you know what let me let me punch on
this question that's a slightly
complicated question
because it'll it'll lead us well
all right i'll talk about a little bit
okay
so is the question of how do we define
so here's a question what's the tallest
mountain in the world
well everybody knows it's mount everest
what does that mean
the tallest mountain in the world well
it means the tallest mountain relative
to wherever the flat
wherever the base is supposed to be what
is the base is the base sea level
what is sea level so for example across
the panama
canal between the atlantic and the
pacific
you would think well there's sea levels
so the atlantic and the pacific must be
at a definite level but they're not
they're a bunch of locks in the panama
canal i forget which one is
is higher i probably should be able to
work it out um
but uh uh you know the atlantic and the
pacific which both presumably aren't sea
level because they're both
seas so to speak are not in fact at the
same level
they're not at the same at the same
distance away from the center of the
earth
so so the question of what's the tallest
mountain
is is potentially quite tricky to define
you know one definition might be what's
the mountain that's that's furthest away
from the center of the earth
another might be what's the mountain and
by the way that would lead you to very
weird results which i'll explain in a
minute
um the uh okay so that might be one
definition of tallest mountain is the
thing that's farthest away from the
center of the earth
another would be what's the thing that's
tallest relative
to whatever you consider the surface of
the earth to be at that place on the
earth
okay why is that a tricky question okay
so
first approximation the earth is a
sphere but it's not exactly a sphere
the earth is rotating obviously once a
day and
that that rotation even though the earth
is is you know
it has it's it's molten inside but it's
you know it's rock it's a pretty
pretty solid kind of thing the the
centrifugal force associated with the
rotation of the earth the fact that you
know like when you when you whirl
something around it tries to pull away
from
from your hand if you're whirling
something around on a string or
something
that that force uh applied to the earth
causes the earth to bulge out in the
middle so to speak so the equator
is bulging out so the earth is flattened
the poles are slightly
if you look at the distance between the
north and south pole it's less than the
distance across the earth at the equator
so the earth is bulging out at the
equator so if we say what's the
what's the highest distance out relative
to the center of the earth will be
something on the equator
because the earth is bulging out at the
equator but so then
what uh how do you decide what is the
what is the surface of the earth you
know what counts as the surface of the
earth
well it's a bit arbitrary but the earth
is a good to a good approximation it's
not exactly a sphere
but it is pretty close to being an
ellipsoid at the three-dimensional
generalization of an ellipse
and so what what ends up happening is
that one defines
there are so called datums which are
defined which are
a particular choice of what ellipsoid
one will be thinking
the the earth corresponds to and
okay so the the um this is getting a
little tricky so back in the
late 1800s there was a chap called
george everest
who was a uh uh a person who was sort of
surveying the earth
and when he came to the himalayas he um
i was looking around at mountains and
things and and trying to work out this
question
about sort of which mountain is highest
relative to
what you can consider the surface of the
earth to be
according to the phillipsoid and he had
a particular ellipsoid that he used to
define the surface of the earth
and relative to that ellipsoid he
determined that this particular mountain
was the tallest mountain and i think
to i gather his his family's frustration
the mountain even though his name was
pronounced everest
the mountain became called everest um
and
uh that was but the determination that
that was the tallest mountain
was a tricky thing now okay so then what
happens
this is the the field of study that
that's involved in this whole question
about datums and so on
is a field called geodesy and um uh in
geodesy
there are a variety of different datums
that people use
and for example it's very convenient to
be able to say
that north america for example which is
essentially one tectonic plate
can be thought of as as having one
uh one datum one little one sort of
effective ellipse a piece of ellipsoid
um but
that datum does not line up properly
with the convenient datum to use for
other parts of the world
when gps became common uh what is it
called
wgs84 i think is the datum that's used
for gps gps because it's global to the
whole earth
you have um uh you have this particular
datum
that um is used to it's an ellipsoid
that is a good approximation to the
ellipsoid for the whole earth
even though the whole earth isn't
precisely an ellipsoid so it's more
convenient if you're just dealing with
north america
to pick a different effective ellipsoid
for just the piece of north america so
so what does this mean in practice
i remember years ago i was had a gps and
i was
driving some car on a beach right by an
ocean
right and i'm looking at my gps and i'm
looking at the little thing you could
press in those days i'm not sure you can
still do that on gps's but you get raw
gps coordinates and so on
and it said that i was 50 feet up
and it's like i mean i knew how this
works i wasn't as confused as it might
have been
but um it's like how could i be 50 feet
up i'm right on the beach
right at sea level the ocean is right
here
how can i be 50 feet up and the answer
is
because sea level is not the zero
of the wgs 84 datum that's used for gps
um so it's a it's sort of a tricky thing
what is the what is the zero
so to speak and and the different oceans
are different heights because
the um uh the the water in the ocean
is um uh is is for example pulled by the
moon different amounts
and so on it's a it's a question of and
and by the rotation of the earth
the water is bulges out different
amounts and so on so it's a
it's a tricky question um what the
actual sort of zero
of of height on the earth is and so if
you start
asking questions like um what's the um
uh you start asking sort of mathematical
questions about working out
you know the total amount of uh oh i
don't know even when you talk about sea
level rise even that's a tricky thing to
define
what that really quite means relative to
uh you know
relative to all these datums and
relatively land and so on and so on and
so on
i mean things happen in um uh in geodesy
there are almost i i don't know whether
a war has ever been fought over geodesy
but um it's certainly come uh somewhat
close because there are things where
people have defined
okay they're also um coordinate systems
where people say
uh given this datum i'm going to define
coordinates to say
where things are on the surface of the
earth and for example let's say there's
an earthquake
and the earth actually moves what do you
do with the coordinate system
or another case is you've got um a
different
um uh you've got uh statements that
my property consists of this thing where
you go one mile in this direction then
you go east and you go half a mile in
that direction and so on and so on and
so on
okay so people have defined those kinds
of things in particular countries
when there are treaties between
countries or when people agree what the
borders between countries are
they're usually written out in those
terms you know go east this distance
from the river you know go this amount
go this amount et cetera et cetera
where does that actually land up well it
can depend on these questions of geodesy
and sometimes it's very tricky and i
know there have been some cases
where people have gotten very uh very
upset
about because it turns out that which
way it goes
depends on whether you get the oil or
whether your neighboring country gets
the oil or you get the gold or your
neighboring country gets the gold
so so these things can be quite tricky
okay
um all right let me see
uh
um
so many questions it's taking me a long
time just to read through these
questions
um
[Music]
um
okay i'm going to take one that says
hello i'm a kid and i have a question
how come one achieve wow is something
quite technical
um how can one achieve file
fragmentation a file system designed for
archive files
for example how can one append x number
of sectors to a static list of
tar posix headers and file data sections
well okay we can unpack that a little
bit um let me let me explain a little
bit about that
it's a technology question i'm not sure
if i'm going to nail this particular
question but maybe it will be of
interest to people
okay so you've got lots of files on your
computer
maybe i've got i might have
10 million files on my computer maybe
you have a hundred thousand files on
your computer
each one has a file name it might be a
dot txt
file it might be a jpeg it's all kinds
of different files on your computer
okay and those files on your computer
are stored in your computer's file
system
what how do they actually get stored and
for example uh
so the file system of your computer
might be it might be an actual spinning
disk these days is more likely a
solid-state disk
it's something where there is an address
for every piece of data in that file
system and it's a linearly arranged
address so it goes from address number
one to address number
you know let's say you have a 100
gigabytes of storage
to address number uh you know 100 100
billion
okay so uh the so
what's happening is every every piece of
data
every byte of every file has to be put
somewhere on the um
on the in in that file system of your
computer
okay so there's a tricky issue that
comes up and
uh and there are different ways to solve
it but here's the tricky issue
let's say you've got 100 gigabytes of
storage available
and and let's say let's make it simpler
let's say you've got one gigabyte
available
and you've got you put in a hundred
megabyte file
okay that takes a tenth of your one
gigabyte of storage
blimp it's put at storage locations
let's say
one through 100 million okay
now you've got another file of a certain
size and you put that down somewhere
else
but now the problem is that you can get
this phenomenon called fragmentation
which is you've you've you've got these
gaps because each file
at least in the first way of doing this
has to be contiguous
like all the bytes all the all the
pieces of data in that file
have to live contiguously in your file
system so
the locations in your file system are
numbered and it has to be the case that
every piece of that file
is just at successive places in your
file system
so then the screwy thing can happen that
particularly when you create a file you
delete a file
you create a file you delete a file
pretty soon you can end up with a
situation where
things are very fragmented where you've
you've allocated you've got
you've got a certain amount of of space
that's been allocated
but there are you know in principle
you've only allocated
let's say 600 megabytes out of your one
gigabyte of storage
but in fact but now you want to put in a
200 megabyte file you say well that's no
problem it should fit
we've got 400 megabytes left but no the
problem is you've not got 400 contiguous
megabytes left
your thing is broken up into all these
different pieces
and there's no hole in there's no
contiguous sequence
of locations in your file system that
will be big enough to fit that 200
megabytes
so that gets very tricky and there are a
variety of solutions to this problem of
fragmentation
um you can your operating system can
move things around and remove that
fragmentation and so on
there are a variety of schemes that are
used and uh
um
i don't know the specifics
of um i mean i could i don't completely
understand this question so i can't
can't
really comment in more detail on it i
mean i i mentioned one other thing
perhaps of interest about files so let's
say you got a file
and it's full of text it's your
you know your your uh school essay
well the question is let's say your
school essay is
um uh let's say
10 000 characters long okay
question is do you need 10 000
bytes do you need 10 000 um
locations to store that 10 000 character
essay
well it turns out you probably don't
because
you can compress it a bit because like
every time you to q
there's a very high probability the next
letter is going to be a u
um and you can use that kind of
information and the fact that different
letters have different frequencies and
so on
to make an encoding of your file
that is less long the file itself and so
there are formats like
zip and um uh things like this
that are archive formats that use
compression
to take uh sort of the the redundant
things like the you after cues and
things like that
effectively it's not really quite how it
works but it effectively takes those
things out to compress
things like english text and with
english text you can usually achieve
about 50
compression so any piece of english text
if you run it through this compression
algorithm
you'll get a file that's half as long
but
the original english text can be
recovered from that file with images
depending on how accurately you want to
reproduce the image and depending on how
much fuzziness you allow
you can sometimes have much huger
compressions factors of 50 factors of a
thousand
and eventually you just have to make a
decision how how accurate you want the
image to be are you prepared to have the
image
um do you want every single pixel to be
right or do you
um is it is it something where you're um
uh
where you're just trying to get
something visually looks more or less
right
um
all right so many different things here
uh
there is um a question here
i'm just about to hit my one hour mark
um
so many interesting questions um
uh that's a question i'd um all right
i'm going to take
a couple more here
uh okay first question is about protein
folding
and do the things that we've studied um
uh have anything to say about that okay
so first of all what is protein folding
what are proteins proteins are the
molecules that
we're pretty much made of um they are
long molecules made up of sequences of
of blocks of atoms called amino acids
and your genome your dna
specifies how to make maybe 30 or 40 000
kinds of proteins and they get made on
demand to make you know hair cells and
to make
blood cells and to make different kinds
of things um
those are that's what we're made of is
proteins and inside each of our cells as
the apparatus to construct
each of these different possible
proteins are specified from our genome
so one of the questions is you've made
this protein it's made from a large
number of units let's say a million
units
of um uh um
uh of sequences of amino acids some
proteins are millions long some people
are
some of them are thousands long and so
on different proteins are different
lengths
um but they're made from sequences of
these blocks of these common they're 20
uh common building blocks 20 kinds of
amino acids
that are used as the building blocks for
for proteins
okay so you've got this long chain of
protein that's made it's sort of
extruded from the ribosomes inside your
cells
when when that protein needs to be made
it's it's constructed
and it's it's long string okay so you've
got this long string of amino acids
the question then is what does this long
string do
and the answer is the long string folds
itself up because there are attractions
different amino acids are attracted to
each other repel each other and so on
the string folds itself up and that
process of folding things up
is both really important for living
systems and really hard to compute
so uh the reason it's important so there
are there are
proteins that don't really fold up much
that are long stringy proteins like
actin
the protein that's in our muscles um is
like that it's a long stringy protein
that um is used to make the fibers in
our muscles
um there'll be a protein like i don't
know hemoglobin
hemoglobin is sort of a protein that
makes kind of a cage
and it has a little little gap in the
middle of the cage that fits just one
iron at a minute and that iron atom is
used to
to uh collect oxygen that's that's used
to transport oxygen in our blood
um or a whole variety of different kinds
of proteins
there are so-called globular proteins
that are made that look like big globs
um there are uh proteins that have
um things called alpha helices which are
long sort of spirals and things called
beta sheets
there are different kinds of shapes that
that show up in different proteins like
for example
a protein whose job is to transport
molecules through the membrane of a cell
it might have an alpha helix which is
like a tube
that's stuck through the the membrane of
the cell and the
the ion like like a um something like a
potassium ion or something or a sodium
ion might
go through that tube through the alpha
helix of the protein
to get through um the the membrane of
the cell
so proteins come in different shapes and
the shapes are very important for the
function of the protein
but the question is if you're just given
here's the sequence of amino acids in a
protein now tell me what shape this
protein is
that's a very hard problem to solve in
nature
proteins do it pretty easily they take
seconds maybe
minutes maybe to fold themselves up and
pretty much
given a protein pretty much folds itself
up in a definite way
at least it does that if it's in water
it might not do the same folding if it
was
not in a water in some different solvent
and sometimes proteins misfold
themselves
sometimes they they're supposed to fold
this way but actually they fold a
different way
and it's possible that alzheimer's
disease has something to do with
misfolding of proteins
and um the uh so
so protein folding matters and protein
folding in nature
happens quite quickly but it's been
awfully difficult to figure out to get
computers
to do accurate folding of proteins and
they've been two basic approaches
one is to just work out all the forces
between the different atoms and the
protein and try and compute
just solve this big uh system it
it might require quantum mechanics but
you can pretty much ignore the quantum
mechanics
and just try and figure out what thing
minimizes the energy by by arranging
these proteins
by arranging the amino acids in in a
different way that's one the so-called
ab initio from first principles
um approach to protein folding the other
way to do protein folding is just to say
well we've got a big database of
proteins that have been folded that
where we know how the thing is folded
um let's just use that database as
training data
and use that to learn how we think
proteins will fold
using something like machine learning
and there's been sort of a there's every
year there's a competition
um for who can do the best protein
folding and i think coach is a
former uh employee of ours actually who
um
uh um as i think i think he won the
competition this last year
but he's been working on the kind of the
machine learning direction and i think
he finally has a scheme
that uses machine learning and that wins
the competition but there's been this
sort of neck and neck
you know is it first principles is it
machine learning that lets you best
predict
how proteins will fold this question
about protein folding one of the
questions is why is it a hard problem
um and that is related to
questions about when when there are
okay so there are class of problems
about
that come up with computers uh with with
defining problems
where um if you could guess the answer
you can check it's right pretty easily
but it can be really hard to guess the
answer
and the many many different tries you
have to make and there's nothing really
guides you
into which guests to try to make
factoring numbers is
is one that's probably like that and
protein folding has
certain attributes that are like that
where if you can kind of guess
the right arrangement to put the protein
into then
then you can verify that it has the
lowest energy but there are
exponentially many there are a huge
number of different possible
configurations
that the protein can go into and in
principle to find which one it has the
lowest energy which one is the
is the one that the protein will tend to
go into it by the way
just to make it even more complicated
the protein doesn't necessarily go into
the lowest energy state
because it matters what the sequence of
foldings is and at each step
it's going to go in nature into the
thing that has certain energy
minimization features
but it's not guaranteed that it finds
the globally minimum energy
what really matters is what what
configuration it goes into in nature
because that's what determines the
activity of the protein um
in in a natural uh system in a
biological system
um so it's tricky thing um and uh
there are um uh
it's yeah it's it's it's complicated and
it's not um
there's still no really good solution
people have been working on this problem
for at least 40 years now
um and uh still difficult it turns out
that some things are easy like rna for
example
um that's actually pretty easy to to
calculate the folding patterns for
proteins are just a really nasty case
all right um there's one last
question here i will
try and address though it's a kind of
complicated one it's from
adenylyl cyclase interesting name
question is is there a relation between
the classification of finite simple
groups
and your physics theory well the first
answer is we don't know
but yet um
but just i'll just try and explain a
little bit about what
the classification of finite simple
groups is all about
see if i can do this okay so
if you take an object wherever i go an
object
let's see what object do i have here oh
it has a nice cubicle object okay so
there's a cube
um okay so if i have this cubicle object
there are certain transformations i can
make unfortunately this isn't exactly a
cube
imagine this is exactly a cube there's
certain transformations that i can make
on this object i can turn it this way i
can rotate it this way i could reflect
it this way and so on
there's certain transformations i can
make on this object which will leave the
object
unchanged you know you know or leave
assuming this was a featureless cube it
didn't have anything in it didn't have
anything written on it
we wouldn't be able to tell the
difference between the cube in that
orientation
and the cube in that orientation and so
on it would be something where
those are symmetries of the queue we're
saying that
that there are a certain number of
possible uh
transformations we can make which will
lead us to an indistinguishable cube
okay now some of those transformations
um we know certain properties of those
transformations like if we have a
transformation
let's say we just we're looking at this
uh even if we're looking at a square
we can do this we can we can take a
transformation that rotates by 90
degrees
the that transmission if we apply it
four times we know we'll get back to
exactly the
the the same thing we started from um
but these um and so we can ask
about what are the different possible
groups of transformations
that have this have certain features
like
um well they have to have they have to
obey certain properties for example
every transformation
there has to be an inverse
transformation there has to be a
transformation that does nothing
there has to be a property of
associativity of transformations
which means if we do two transformations
and then we do a third one
it's the same as doing one
transformation and then doing two more
so with those properties and those are
true of of
transformations that we make on kind of
regular objects
and that collection of transformations
is called a mathematical group
um and the question then is uh
if we just say well we've got the
possible transformations of a cube we've
got the possible transformations of a
square we've got possible transmissions
of
hedron um what possible sets of
transformations
are there that we can set up that have
the properties
that i described for a group
associativity inverses
and existence of identity so
that question was um
there are an infinite number of possible
collections of such transformations
but they fall into certain definite
families and
there was a big project in the 1970s and
1980s particularly
to try and classify exactly what buckets
of transformations
that make groups there could be and um
as i say there's some infinite families
like you can have the group of any
polygon
you can have a polygon with any number
of sides the group of the 117
sided polygon is different from the
group of 118 sided polygon
you do that for any any size of polygon
it's a cyclic group of order n um
and uh actually it's not just the cyclic
group there's a little bit more to it
than just the cyclic group because of
reflections
but um anyway the the um uh
uh so in any case you can you can
classify these
different possible transformations that
you can make well
um so there's a big project to try and
find what are all the families of
different transformations
some of them are very straightforward
families like they're associated with
polygons of different
sizes but there's some very exotic ones
and there's a particularly exotic one
there's a sequence of really exotic ones
and that is a finite sequence it ends in
this thing called the monster group
which is this group of transformations
that has a huge number of elements i
forget how many it's in the
trillions at least maybe more than that
and maybe trillion trillions i'm not
sure
of possible transformations um that
are not transformations of anything that
we
are familiar with like cubes and things
like that it's transformations in some
mathematical object um but that set of
transformations it has a certain degree
of elegance because it is
the exceptional the only the last the
biggest
sort of uh exotic special uh
finite group um and uh so that and that
group has many interesting properties
and many things that are important in
mathematics turn out to be sub cases of
that group
and so it is possible that in our
theories of physics
that um in particular the the um
uh that there may be some things which
are effectively coming out
from something like the monster group
this this biggest group
it's a little bit tricky because there
are some they're not just finite groups
they're also infinite groups
which have an infinite number of
transformations in them and there are
also things called league groups
i like lie groups um
that uh named after a trap called
sophist lee who is norwegian
um the lead groups are groups that have
a continuous set of possible
transformations they're kind of the
analog of calculus
for groups um where one has not just a
discrete set oh we can
rotate the the the square by by 90
degrees
but you can rotate the the object like a
circle by any angle
however small that angle is the the the
symmetry group of the circle is a lead
group
a continuous group it's called u1 um
the uh the group of the circle and that
um and that's a that's another kind of
group
and and and trying to make contact with
physics
most likely what's going to be relevant
is lead groups
and in fact in our in our models of
physics
uh which are discrete models of physics
which have only just
this sort of uh this this lead group
arises
as a continuous as a limit of a very
large sized
um object um and and how that limit
works
is um uh you're sort of taking the limit
if you have if you have enough
it's like the limit of if you have
enough molecules in your water the water
will seem continuous
if you have enough sides in your polygon
the polygon will seem like a continuous
circle
and and that's the way in which we get
these kind of regroup type things
but it's conceivable that in the way
from our from our discrete system
through to something like the lead
groups that correspond to the so-called
gauge groups
that are fundamental to particle physics
um that
uh um that we will um that will end up
going through this monster group
all right i think i should wrap up there
uh thank you very much for lots of
interesting questions i'm sorry i didn't
get to everybody's question um
uh today uh please um
uh drop in again next week and i will
try and get to uh
some more of these questions thanks a
lot bye for now